quelle meilleure manière de vous montrer
le site de fallot sunshine que de
laisser un aux résidents vous en faire
la visite
moi c'est pour ça que tu pas reconnue
apte à l'heure d'une momie tu veux dire
été mon premier client
c'était un des humoristes les plus
drôles de l'époque je le bouquet dans
tout le pays j'ai reçu un coup de fil
est solide
le rêve de tous les comics du coup vous
avez fait quoi je suis devenu baudelot
c'est tombé le show biz pour les pieds
oui ça ne manque pas quoi pour que tu ne
l'ès pas se trouver ce que ta douce est
arrêtée depuis 50 ans justement ce sera
un come-back extraordinaire à des rôles
10 dollars qui vont pas jusqu'à les
terres je vais te couper à vegas à caen
jouera à chicago je vais aussi de
bouquets à ce [ __ ] de tonight show
mais demande d'applaudir pas d'y créer
j'ai décidé de revenir et de faire pour
rigoler personnes rigole pauvre il n'a
pas baissé depuis qu'il était
conditionnée au fait très jolie un
sketch déjà mule sketches mais j'ai 50
ans d'histoires drôles
ma femme adorait faire l'amour sa
position préférée était la position du
missionnaire
c'est à dire elle dans son livre sur le
dos et moi en afrique
quand on arrivera à new york tu seras au
top de sa forme
tu as eu des nouvelles de des gens de
carson tu retarde de deux trains dites
moi ce que vous faites ici à kansas city
et bien je suis en tournage x sûr que
vous étiez une rock-star grand-père est
tu voudrais que je peux me réjouir que
tu as enfin trouvé d'avoir 80 ans
exactement
al air d merci c'est mon boulot
[Applaudissements]
huawei n'ont pas tous au nom du dieu
qu'est-ce que d'accord c'est moi qui les
ai acheté ta drogue je te prendrai une
tonne de pétards maui et de space cake
salut saül dites moi vous êtes tous
super cool j'en suis certain non en fait
je voudrais acheter un peu de marijuana
ou du shit et fait des études
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]